All right, all right.
Good morning, everybody. How's everybody doing?
Good, good.
So my name is Kyle Goodwin. I'm the senior vice
president of sales and operations for Spectral Cloud.
I'm excited to have with me here
today. Shiv
Arihapan
is the vice president of Global reliability
Engineering for Yum Brands,
as well as Ryan Good, director of reliability
and platform engineering, and Justin Swaggler,
AWS worldwide head of physical
retail.
So we're actually here today to discuss
how we together as an organ as
three organizations have reinvented
retail edge.
So we'll kick off with them actually telling us a
little bit about themselves. So Shiv, we'll start with
you. All right, thank you. Uh,
hi everyone, I'm Shiv Adapin.
Uh,
I'm, uh, I lead the global reliability engineering
at Yum Brands.
Uh, as you all know, Yum Brands owns Taco
Bell, KFC, Pizza Hut, and the Habit Burger,
and, uh, I've been with the company for
the last 5 years, uh, focusing on the
site reliability engineering,
instant management, and scalability for our platforms.
Yeah, I'm Ryan Good.
I lead our reliability
and platform engineering, so a lot of our
developer enablement, but also infrastructure,
all the, all the fun stuff that actually sells
the pizza, the chicken, the tacos that
we have, so.
And lastly, Justin Swaggler,
part of AWS. I serve as worldwide head
of physical retail.
So any and everything as we think about
technology experiences, operations,
and innovation across physical retail,
restaurants, and consumer goods, I'm
owning from that side from an AWS.
Excellent. Thanks guys. So,
Yum Brands runs thousands of
locations globally, and tech innovation
is happening not just in the cloud, but
also at the edge.
So today we're actually gonna explore how Yum, AWS,
and Spectral Cloud
are reinventing that in-store architecture
to deliver agility, AI, and
scalability.
So let's start with, with you, Shiv. What
sparked this transformation in the first place
at Yum? Yeah, um, I
mean, Yam is the largest restaurant chain in
the world. They operate out of 155
countries. Um,
the journey for selling our
food product has been transforming into
more of digital,
and, uh, 5 years ago when I joined Yum
right before joining Yum,
Yum decided to kind of own its own
technology, build their own first party technology
platform to run the restaurant ecosystem end
to end. As you kind of do that, you're
building your cloud platforms, your digital platforms.
In-store becomes such a key part of it because it's
a customer journey at one end and there's the restaurant
operations and our store operators
experience on the other end.
So it basically comes together to form the ecosystem
and we basically have been building the modular
product ecosystem over the last 5 years
and we've, uh, scaled a lot of our products we
call like by Bay.
It's scaled across, uh,
like 20,000+ restaurants, uh,
already. So how, how
is that, and, and, and I think you and Ryan can tag
team this a little bit, but
how is that increased the speed of your
operation, uh, up time? Has it impacted the
uptime agility overall?
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, for sure. So I think, um, especially
with, uh, the way that we think of platform
engineering and we think of building platforms
that are self-service, right?
One of the, the key things is, you know, you
have these operations issues in
the restaurants that can now be handled
at the level. Level one help desk,
right? They can
see and, and have visibility, but then
also the tooling to take action
to restart workloads that might be hung up and
restart those POS devices that, you
know, throw up errors
before even having to escalate it to some of those
level threes or those, those higher level engineers,
so you stop that cycle much faster and so you
get them back into business a lot quicker.
So yeah, absolutely huge unlock
for that. Yeah, I mean to add to that,
uh. Operating a restaurant,
taking orders means even if Internet goes
down, cloud goes down, the last
mode for us is running the order
taking process and it's important that the in-store
technology supports that it's the backbone of our sales.
Excellent.
So from, from AWS's perspective,
Justin, what are some of the
key architectural elements of the services
that make it possible to run AIML
workloads? Yeah, really underpinning
that comes down to creating a unified
kind of management system as you think
about Kubernetes and your applications across
any channel,
right? And underpinning that is. Amazon
EKS hybrid nodes which AWS
announced last year at reinvented
this time and it's really accelerating
the journey for customers like Yum,
other retailers that I engage with
around the world as they think about creating
that unified management
experience,
right? Yum Brands, what, 40,000
locations have lots of locations, right?
Across edge devices and all
those applications, right? That's a lot of
locations that have to be managed as far as
doing modernization,
deploying new applications. And
with EKS hybrid nodes powered
by spectral cloud, that gives you kind of a
single pane of glass, right? A
control plane to allow you to get that visibility.
As far as what am I running, where
am I having issues, how can I resolve
those and to do that quickly and
modernize that what in a period of, of
days or weeks versus months and
years that other customers are dealing with,
um, in the past
and that's fundamental because you think
about from a retail and consumer
industry standpoint,
you know, we as shoppers, we shop all channels
mobile digital voice
in physical locations and by
having that unified control plane.
That allows you to better manage that
experience from any touch point that a
shopper's going through.
So that's kind of one fundamental aspect is with EKS
hypernodes. The second comes down as you think about
like a resilient edge and AI
applications that you start to bring in to those
locations. So if I do model training
on a sage maker or with Bedrock in
the cloud,
I can start to
deploy lightweight.
AI models or applications
directly at the edge
that are really custom fit to the workload
to the use case that I'm trying to solve and
again by having that hybrid
unified
architecture that really allows
for customers like Yum to start to bring
those applications into their stores.
Thanks, Justin. So
we talk a lot about being better together
just across the industry.
So from a, a collaboration perspective,
this obviously spans Yum,
Spectral Cloud, and AWS.
So how do, what is each partner's role? So
we'll start, we'll start with you, Shiv. But what,
what do you, how do you think each partner's role really
shaped the overall solution?
Yeah, I mean, I think it's, we couldn't build
everything. That's the fundamental part of it. While we own the
first party technology and platform, we had to choose
the right partner solution for
our architecture, the ecosystem that we're building
in. Uh, ADBS4 has been, uh,
a very strong partner for over the years, and,
uh, what we do is like essentially we,
we work with them closely, we bring our solution
roadmap architecture
together, and then what, uh, ADBS
does really well for us is like connect us,
essentially do the matchmaking with appropriate
solutions that's out there. It's just not like one
solution go with this is like you got all these options that
you can try it out and etc. is one of those things where we
had a. Uh, solution, I think you mentioned, uh,
right, Justin,
we gotta start thinking about the in-store
or the edge workloads, not as separate,
it's part of the cloud ecosystem
because the second you start thinking about it as, uh,
something different,
then you start, uh, fragmenting
your solutions and that's kind of where bringing
in like a
Kerics-based solution, some of those things,
becomes more critical for us.
Any anything to add, Ryan? Yeah, I
think that's exactly it. It's, it's having a
thought partner
in AWS that can bring us to those
different solutions is huge, right? Um,
not only that, like we, we do, we
can't see everything. We don't have those
relationships with a lot of vendors, and so they,
again, like she said, are the matchmakers
when it comes to that.
But then, you know, to the point of like, all
right, we have.
You know this, this ecosystem that we've been building
that that the same teams
that build
for the cloud also need to
be able to build for the edge right so we can
with that kind of uh partnership
and single layer that single pane of
glass
have the same teams building workloads and
AI whatever that might be
all the way through our entire ecosystem so yeah
it's huge. Yeah, I mean, in general
from an AWS standpoint, partners are fundamental
to how we help customers
like young brands
being able to provide the right type of
ISVs and partners like a Spectral cloud
to tackle some of those meaty challenges
underpinned by AWS and Amazon
services,
but then also how can we be that strategic
partner with you.
To go even beyond just from a
spectral side, right? How do we think about bringing in the
AI if we're looking at computer vision
and IOT and Agentic
inside of your containers,
right? How can AWS build on top of that
with you, powered by spectral
cloud to then
really create that unlock? So it is truly a
1 + 1 equals 3 long
term. Yeah, I think, uh, just to add on
a little bit to that is like connecting us even with
other customers that are doing some of these
things, you know, we think about reliability
and you think about as we start to look at
scaling these things to the edge.
We can't be everywhere and so even that
example I gave about, you know, level ones
and being able to click some buttons and restart pods,
eventually that needs to be automated, right? And so
going out and being connected with
customers that are already doing some of those things
and learning from them and best practices
and, and what models to use and
like all that kind of stuff,
right? Like that's where getting in those rooms and
making those connections is, is key for that.
Got it. That's actually a good segue to kind of
the, the, the sub part of the question which
is what we see a lot in the
industry is aligning
enterprise needs with, with Edge
and AI innovation. What lessons
did you guys learn in that process from
a young perspective?
Yeah, I mean, I'll, I'll jump in here, uh,
so one of the things that we wanted to do is
like Edge
is a solution that gets into the
restaurant that stays there for like 5 years, 10
years, then how do you build for modernization
scalability with that?
So
one of the ideas and remember Ryan, myself
and a couple of our team members early on before
going into the solutioning phase is we
have to extend the edge into the cloud.
Think about a world where.
Your 8 servers also a container
like it's just a note running in the restaurant
and what it would take to scale the workloads from Edge
into the cloud
that was kind of like the key key underpinning
of like futureproofing our technology, right?
Like otherwise 5 years later, 10 years later, all
these new hardware comes in a lot more efficient.
Then you just can't truck roll
everywhere to go recycle all those things
so that was
definitely a tricky one where keep the cost low
if you do want to extend it, build it modular in
a way where you do this and then make sure
that it's future proofd enough to leverage
the infinite scale of the cloud
that you normally want to use there for. I, I think
to build on that right with, with what you've
done here with Spectro, right? That's fundamental.
That's part of. Your foundation, you know, if we want to bring
in AI,
if I want to bring in all these cool agentic
capabilities, but I don't have the foundation
set up correctly, like you're setting
yourself up to fail, right? So
a lot of our customers are realizing the
potential of, yes, I need to modernize. I
need to better connect and unify
my edge,
my Kubernetes into the cloud, etc.
so that I can streamline that.
Reduce my IT overhead costs
by a significant amount,
have full resiliency,
low latency,
no downtime, so that then
I have that foundation built to
then start to do like those proof of
concepts, right? Starting small,
scaling it from there, and then driving
further value.
100% unlocks a lot more workloads
that we haven't thought about yet. We have use cases that we're building
based off of, but you have the infrastructure now.
Now you
the time to market for a new functionality feature
drastically reduces when you have the infrastructures
ready to go.
So all, all of the hard work that we're
doing here is really
in my mind about a few things, but we'll talk about one
here which is improving the
customer experience, right?
And so.
In knowing, and Ryan, this is for you, knowing
that Yum is prioritizing, you know,
AI and GPU workloads overall,
can you give us some concrete examples of how AWS
and Spectro together
are actually doing that for Yum?
Yeah, so I think um one of the
big things is, you know, when you think about real-time
data analytics. Right? Like, a
lot of times right now, especially if we don't have this
stuff running at the edge,
you're having to ship that up to the cloud to do your analysis.
It may not be relevant
anymore, right? By the time you get that
information down to those store managers
or to those franchisees,
OK, cool, that's a week old. There's nothing
I can do for that, right?
So as you look at kind of where it's going in the
future of being able to analyze
that real-time locally,
they can start to take action then and then you start
to build agents and you start to be able to,
to say, OK, now automatically take action,
that's gonna allow those store managers
or store employees to focus on the things that matter,
which is the customer experience, right?
If you, if you think about retail and you think of,
like I remember back in the day when I worked. And retail
and my manager would be in the office
running those reports constantly, right? Like
every 20-30 minutes they disappear, they'd
be gone for an hour and they'd come back, oh, here's the latest
sales report.
What if all of that was just automated and they had the
action they could do all of that, they could spend
time with the customers, they could be out there greeting
them, they could
really enhance their experience
coming into your retail store
or into your restaurant.
And then you have our other line employees
who can focus on making better quality food. They
can focus on the things that matter
to them rather than,
oh shoot, uh, we're out of tacos. Uh, we're
out of tortillas. I was about to go there. I was about to go
there with tacos, right? Exactly. So like
those things can really hamper
the operations. And if you take all of
that out of their mental
load and they just have smooth
operations, customers are gonna benefit. The
employees are gonna benefit.
Everyone's gonna benefit.
Yeah, I mean one thing I'll add on to that is like the
customer experience is one thing, the team members
experience is easy as equally important
to us.
That's how you get the best food out to the customers
as fast as possible and our goal was always
just make the technology work. It's like
email like somebody said it before, it just, it should work
and how do you make it, make it happen is basically
build that right infrastructure underneath it then
you kind of like remove the technology from
how things work where it's not in your face.
You're not having your restaurant, uh, team members
become. Like their own tech people like trying to unplug
and replug wires and things like that.
So I, I mean, to me like the operational
side, the benefit that comes out of that has
been a huge thing for us
outside of, I mean, there's definitely business use cases that we can
run from an AIML workload perspective, but
we have our own, like half of our containers, our own
internal containers, core containers, because
we could do so much more observ, streamlining
the connectivity back into the cloud,
like funneling through 111 node
up rather than having like 20 different devices
shipping logs to the cloud, things like that.
I mean, of consumer industries, right, retail,
restaurants, consumer goods, right?
Providing that real-time
proactive visibility. If an agent
or your
containers can tell me an issue
before I,
as a
restaurant manager, as a store manager,
even before I know.
And be able to respond to that, that's driving
value, right? I mean, if your cookers
fail, right, and you don't know until
after it happens,
that's bad,
right? And how by deploying
this kind of modern unified
infrastructure,
it can start to predict it ahead of time so that I
can resolve it ahead of time, right, which drives
the experience. Operational stability part is
workloads that basically saying rather than saying something's
wrong, it says what exactly is wrong,
then you're jumping into the recovery part of it. As fast
as you can and it's critically important
given, I mean,
yes, digital commerce is growing, but
even younger generations still want
the experience inside of stores, right?
So again, you can really focus on
that experience, making sure it's seamless,
it's connected, and that it's providing a
great experience for your shoppers.
So Justin, since you're on the mic,
technology is rapidly evolving, especially as we keep
talking about with AI
and, and really data-driven retail overall.
How do you see cloud to edge architecture
adapting and evolving
over the next few years to keep retailers
like Yum actually ahead of the curve?
Yeah, I, I, I mean, Agente is going to be a
big area that's coming over the next couple
of years. We're starting to build that now with customers
as we think about in physical locations,
but I mean, a lot of the research that we're seeing
across the industry, I mean, 90% of retailers
are going to be investing in AI algorithms
at the edge. They're going to be deploying
that to reduce
costs in IT. They're going to be doing that
to improve workforce efficiency,
make them,
you know, even if they save 30, 40 minutes of
their time.
In the day and they can focus on the experience,
right? So those are the trends that are shaping
how customers like Yum need to architect
and the types of applications they need to
build to be able to promote some of that.
So in essence, I mean the evolution
is going to be starting that whole real time,
right? I have that infrastructure.
I'm now capturing IOT data,
all this other data. I'm able to analyze
it in real time. I'm able to
respond, whether it is solving an
issue, whether it's personalization,
retail media,
engagement,
etc. to be able to really
create a. Much more seamless
experience not just for the shopper but
also your workforce as well.
Yeah, one thing I'll add is there's two parts, right?
One is
the small language models that's locally
running. The other one is
the spaghette for the connectivity that
allows to take
a big workload, ship it out to the cloud asynchronously,
get the response back, and you need that edge
component to be able to play that role as well.
All right guys, so we're coming, coming up on
time. Quick rapid fire. We'll start with
you, Shiv. What's one piece of advice you'd
give to other tech leaders trying to modernize? How
do they not get left behind?
Yes, I think.
Understand it, like thinking through the ecosystem
and adding those puzzle pieces is gonna be
such a key part.
It's so hard to take all these pieces
and try to make it work together.
So, uh, we do this ecosystem diagram
where everything just needs to connect and loop back in. Nothing
just stays on the site somewhere.
So I think that's such an important vision part of it.
I, I say that building things is now easy.
It's the thinking, the strategy part is the hard now.
Awesome, Ryan, one piece of advice. One
piece of advice would be lean in to,
to just trying things. I think you can't,
you can't be afraid to just try something new and,
and put it out there, um, and
I think the strategy thing is exactly it.
Like, think about all of those,
the things you're trying to solve,
look at it as like a multifaceted.
Piece, not just like a single slice, right? You
think about
all of the aspects of that thing that you're trying
to solve
customer,
employee, business, like all of that
is part of it.
Hopefully then just leaning in on trying
some of those things and, and realizing you're not gonna
get it right,
but if you build it in a way to be modular,
you can enhance it later. Awesome, Justin.
I mean, one of our Amazonian principles is around
starting small,
right? Test it out, proof of concept,
explore, right? Be a bit curious
around what can technology like
a hybrid approach
from an edge and cloud,
what can that unlock for you? Start small
and then scale it from there. But
also
modernization
like this is a meaty challenge,
right? It can feel overwhelming of
like, wow, I really need to completely change
what I'm doing.
Right? And that's why it's important to start
small, try that out, and
slowly start to slice away
at bringing those kind of capabilities and that
with a strategic view long term,
you know, as Shiv and Ryan have talked about and
starting small, I think that helps set
the foundation
for allowing to really accelerate
overall modernization.
Excellent guys. So what you guys have heard
today is really the power of 3
organizations coming together for one mission,
and that mission was to help Yum deliver
consistent,
reliable, and innovative experiences
to their customers.
So give them a round of applause
for what they've been able to deliver.
And, and overall, we've really, AWS
provides that global foundation, global scalable
foundation,
Spectral Cloud delivering that operating layer
from a Kubernete's perspective,
and then Yum bringing the vision as Shiv has
talked about, as Ryan has talked about, really driving
with that strategy
that pushes all to reinvent.
So if we can make infrastructure invisible,
we can accelerate transformation. So
thank you all.